und erstmal respekt dass sie sich noch
freiwillig eine sendung über wahlkampf
reinziehen ja man ist übersättigt oder
doch egal wo du rein selbst in diesen
tagen die drei kandidaten sind schon da
mir ist das zu viel ja und was man gar
nicht mehr braucht wirklich gar nicht
mehr braucht sind diese elenden tv
totale zeitverschwendung dieses im
schweinsgalopp durch alle themen hetzen
das bringt null erkenntnisgewinn ist
also das einzige was wir letzten sonntag
gelernt haben von tri l nummer zwei ist
wenn man olaf scholz auf geldwäsche
anspricht kriegt der rote ohren ja ja
ist aber geklärt das war wohl nur ein
software fehler im scholzomat die haben
dann einfach aus und wieder angeknipst
seitdem läuft er wieder fehlerfrei und
in den umfragen zeichnet sich ja
zumindest eine vorsichtige trendwende
die union ist wieder etwas näher an die
spd heran gerückt gibt es also doch noch
hoffnung für hier dings das zweite trial
hat gestern abend stattgefunden zwischen
den kanzlerkandidaten annalena baerbock
olaf scholz und achim laschet also
entschuldigung frau kollegin aber den
sollte man schon drauf haben ja den
namen von potenziellen nachfolger von
angelika merkel dafür zahle ich keine
gebühren freunde ja insgesamt für mich
ein merkwürdiges troja laschet und
scholz haben sich angezeigt und die
werburg stand dazwischen wie so ein
scheidungskind ne ja bald musste sich
festlegen ob sie in der koalition bei
mama oder papa wohnen will selten so
eine sinnlose sendung gesehen
zwei typen scheuen sich an und eine frau
hörzu 2 bei berbalk die neue nachmittags
talkshow ab sofort bei rtl
[Musik]
und cooper immerhin bleibt spannend wie
es aussieht laut allensbach sind 40
prozent der deutschen noch
unentschlossen aber herr scholz tritt in
interviews auf als wäre er praktisch
schon kanzler der präsidial fast schon
merkel es geht ja nicht nur für union
und grüne ich sage auch bei den sozen
wären andere kandidaten möglich gewesen
ich sag's nur unter anderem einer der
besten freien mitarbeiter der heute-show
lauterbach hätte kanzlerkandidat der spd
werden sollen er hätte löschen laschet
als dreck
x8 karl den tweet hast du doch selber
geschrieben aber vorsicht vor
überheblichkeit luschen laschet cdu hat
gerade die kommunalwahl in niedersachsen
geworden und das ist ja schon mal völlig
irrelevanten speziell bei der frage nach
der kanzlerpräferenz sieht es nach wie
vor nicht gut aus für den 8 in den
umfragen umso verstörender diese
backstage party szenen beim tri l an sie
ist gesehen irgendwelche nur cube von
der jungen union hatten sich da was
total wichtiges ausgedacht und den film
wolf of wall street gezeigt aber jetzt
kommt mit super witzigen untertitel hier
wir gewinnen diese bundestagswahl
ja also mal für alle die den film nicht
kennen dicaprio spielt einen zu
gekürzten kriminellen börsenzocker ist
das wirklich eine gute metapher für die
cdu obwohl
im übrigen liebe video ag der junge
union wenn muss man das natürlich
synchronisieren ist das mindeste und sie
glauben gar nicht wie oft leonardo
dicaprio armin laschet gespielt hat die
offen fragen sagen hat 21 grad
als lose aber das ist vorbei und ihr
meint das ist die idee die unserem
wahlkampf rettet ja klar armee sobald
die wähler dein gesicht nicht mehr sehen
können haben wir das ding im sack
ja vielleicht wird das ja noch ne union
und spd liegen jetzt ziemlich nah
beieinander in diesem duell ja ja nix
tree
lnw er hat sich sang- und klanglos aus
dem kanzlerin verabschiedet und die
umfragewerte seit april fast halbiert
wie er die grünen schon
wieder richtig ost so aber warum ist ihr
traum geplatzt aller wahrscheinlichkeit
nach nicht zuletzt wegen verblüffend und
professioneller fehler der grünen im
wahlkampf klar und trotzdem müsste das
doch eigentlich das ja der grünen sein
nach diesem extremwetter sommer so in
einer umfrage zu den ängsten der
deutschen landet der klimawandel aber
nur auf platz elf
eine große mehrheit der deutschen ist
zwar für klimaschutz aber nur wenn man
ihn nicht merkt ja oder nur wenig quasi
neu anfangen mit weiter so klarer fall
für die
heuchlerische ja immer an die eigene
nase fassen freunde politiker lesen
umfragen und dann kriegt man als bürger
eben die politik die man verdient zum
beispiel sagen aktuell knapp 60 prozent
der über 65-jährigen silenen ist ab beim
wählen klimaschutz interessen zu
berücksichtigen ja genau deshalb reicht
es als politiker eben völlig zu sagen
man ist für mehr klimaschutz oder sich
zum 1,5 grad zu bekennen nicht ziel das
wäre zu verbindlich es folgt der
wahrscheinliche dümmste satz in der
geschichte des deutschen fernsehens und
das will etwas heißen armin laschet
verspricht das
dass ich sie machen lasse dass wir ihnen
nicht vorschreiben
wie sie zu denken haben und wie sie zu
reden haben und wie sie zu leben haben
und so können wir es gemeinsam schaffen
ein klimaneutrales industrieland zu
werden wo
haben sie den zusammenhang verstanden
wenn alle machen was sie wollen werden
wir klimaneutral verspricht der mann der
erst vor wenigen wochen den bau von
windrädern in nordrhein-westfalen
ausgebremst hat was fällt einem dazu
noch ein
dass uschi glas ich mit solchen leuten
sehen lässt traurig olaf scholz übrigens
ist auch voll für klimaschutz aber er
möchte dabei zitat aus dem trio einen
moderaten weg gehen ja weil er so ein
moderator typ ist kann funktionieren
müssen sie halt im aartal fürs nächste
mal auf moderates hochwasser hoffen
nicht dass es hinterher heißt das ist
einfach
schlecht gelaufen
fun fact allein der neue hochwasser
hilfsfonds für 2021 allein der ist 30
milliarden euro schwer trotzdem wurde im
trial nur nach den kosten des
klimaschutzes gefragt und dann sagt sie
ihre berbalk auch noch das v wort
jedes verbot ist auch ein
innovationstreiber
unglücklich formuliert wenn verbote
innovationstreiber sind anna-lena warum
ist nordkorea dann nicht sinken wenn
einfach mal drüber nachdenken obwohl
andererseits wenn ich darüber nachdenke
erst seit man vw die beschiss software
verboten hat bauen sie wie blöde e autos
trotzdem haben sich sogar die grünen von
der anti verbots hysterie im land
anstecken lassen nichts mehr
kurzstreckenflüge verbieten dem
aktuellen wahlprogramm heißt es nur noch
zug um zug überflüssig machen folge
selbst das grüne klimaprogramm geht laut
wissenschaft nicht weit genug ja der
deutsche hast haltverbote so wie damals
in den siebzigern wissen sie noch als
von uns plötzlich verboten hat bei
unfällen durch die windschutzscheibe zu
fliegen beamte gurtpflicht
sie sind nicht angeschnallt warum nicht
ich habe mich selten an dass du mit
eingriff in die persönliche freiheit und
der ist ja laut grundgesetz die
möglicherweise nicht angeschnallt das
selbstverständlich aus überzeugung nicht
aus überzeugung weil ich wills um eine
frau will das auch ja und was lernen wir
daraus nicht alle verbote sind blöd und
echter klimaschutz kommt wahrscheinlich
erst wenn meine frau das will das war
wie heute
christian lindner dagegen setzt beim
klima aufkommende erfindungen und er
ackert sich kaputt fürs land kennen sie
sein plakat er sitzt da jede nacht im
büro und verdirbt sich die augen für uns
andererseits habe ich mich gefragt was
genau macht eigentlich der mann regiert
doch gar nicht aber bald vielleicht die
fdp gilt als königsmacher vor allem bei
den jungen wählern sind die liberalen in
umfragen
erschreckend erfolgreich liegt
wahrscheinlich am style
irgendwann kommt der punkt an dem du
weißt so wie es ist darf es nicht
bleiben zu viel ist liegen geblieben
die digitalisierung ist kein nebenthema
digitalisierung ist das überlebens thema
der klimawandel muss bekämpft werden mit
freude am erfinden nicht am verbieten
und das alles beschäftigt dich bis tief
in die nacht und du weißt du musst etwas
tun nicht irgendwann sondern jetzt
warten wir nicht länger nie gab es mehr
zu tun
wow oder also wirklich nicht schlecht
einziger kleiner kritikpunkt ich finde
sie hätten noch ein bisschen öfter
christian lindner zeigen können nur
meine meinung aber wie gesagt der style
einfach nur top irgendwann kommt der
punkt an dem du weißt dass du vielleicht
bald mit spd und grünen regieren muss
deswegen guckst du in deinem unfassbarem
schwarz weiß film er ist nachdenklich
dann traurig dann panisch zu viel ist
liegen geblieben du musst etwas tun
hier sieht aus wie sau
digitalisierung warum hat mich jeder
deutsche längst eine eigene vr brille
steuern senken aber keine neuen schulden
machen geht gar nicht damit das aufgeht
müsste man mal was er finden zum
beispiel eine ganz neue mathematik aber
eine andere frage warum sitz ich hier
nur mit einer beschissenen 20 watt kunze
und warum wird mein auge immer so
ekelhaft nagel 2
und um davon abzulenken dass unser
fdp-steuerkonzept reiche schon wieder
deutlich reicher macht zeigen wir
wahllos irgendwelche bilder thomas
surfer fischkutter oder meerschweinchen
die eine banane fressen das alles
beschäftigt dich bis tief in die nacht
und du weißt du musst etwas tun oder
du machst sie einfach noch ein bier
aufmachen wir nicht länger prost
die a-note hassknecht packt mit an bei
der fdp weil wir nicht länger warten
dürfen und ich sage mal egal ob ampel
oder jamaika die nächste regierung wird
in jedem fall eine schwere geburt ja ich
fürchte das zieht sich hin bis weit ins
nächste jahr die koalitionsverhandlungen
bis januar/februar wird mindestens durch
fahndet und wenn es blöd läuft heißt es
am ende wahrscheinlich
und wenn wir es noch mal versuchen bitte
nicht wenn meine eigentlich ist nur bei
der afg 100 prozent sicher dass die
nicht regieren
dafür müsste schon der reichstag brennen
ja die afg oder wie sie seit dieser
woche heißt die partei der dichter und
denker
denn es wird ihnen nicht entgangen sein
timo grub aller hier einer der beiden
parteichefs der afg hat uns gerade im
zwiegespräch mit einem jungen logo
reporter diese absolute sternstunde
geschenkt sie wollen außerdem an den
schulen mehr deutsches kulturgut
einfüllen was bedeutet das eigentlich
wir möchten wir dass das wieder mehr
deutsche volkslieder geleert werden dass
die deutsche gedichte gelernt werden
dass wir auf unsere deutschen dichter
und denker wieder mehr in den schulen
würdiger was ist denn ihr
lieblingsgedicht eigentlich
finde ich mein lieblingsgedicht ist er
muss ich jetzt müsste ich jetzt mal
überlegen fed cup teams ein nicht ganz
wunderbar der junge kann morgen bei uns
anfangen sieht er aus wie der junge ralf
kabelka kino kubala poetry slammer aus
leidenschaft bestehen sie bitte jetzt
auf gar keinen fall dass hier
[Musik]
jetzt neu im afg shop die exklusive cd
box die schönsten deutschen gedichte
gelesen von timo grub allah mit
klassikern wie heinrich heines puder
erwischen sie mich jetzt komplett auf
dem falschen fuß oder schillers
legendärem lied von der hier dieses
dings was oben im kirchturm and und
natürlich goethes da müsste ich mal
überlegen das eine wo der typ mit dem
kind auf dem pferd weiß auch nicht
natürlich auch als gute alte
musikkassette sofort bestellen unter www
scheiße jetzt fällt mir die adresse gar
nicht ein
also die afg kämpft für deutsche lyrik
und ganz aktuell gegen die briefwahl man
erwartet in deutschland den höchsten
anteil ever und die afg wittert betrug
dazu begrüße jetzt aus der
wahlkampfzentrale der alternative zu ihm
hält hausten draußen das deutsche
wahlsystem ist doch eines der
transparentesten und sichersten der welt
das ist ihre meinung ich kann ihnen
jetzt schon versprechen wir werden das
ergebnis in jedem fall anfechten also
außer jetzt wir schneiden doch
überraschend gut ab weil dann ist ja
offensichtlich alles mit rechten dingen
zugegangen rechten bild einfach nicht
gut ja ja ja
ich meine man kann doch nicht schöne
ausrede nach einem möglicherweise ein
ergebnis einfach mal das vertrauen in
die demokratie an sich erschüttern ist
doch total skrupellos sprach der
zwangsgebühren hartgeld stricher vom
staatsfernsehen
entschuldigung aber wir haben schon
2018 fdp-politiker als wahlbeobachter
nach russland geschickt und da war
soweit alles okay gewesen also wir
erkennen schon wenn wahlen demokratisch
ablaufen aber was hier läuft ist eben
nicht mehr demokratisch und das hat das
deutsche volk zu erfahren diejenigen die
für die briefwahl werbung machen das
sind vor allen dingen die kartell
parteien das sind die die bei ihrer oma
grün wählen und gleichzeitig auch noch
das kreuz der oma bei den grünen machen
jetzt können sie gerne wieder ihre dicke
naserümpfen weil ihn das nicht gefällt
was unser bernd da sagt aber genauso
läuft hier mit versteckter kamera
gedrehten bilder aus dem joschka fischer
seniorenstift in kreuzberg so ein
löffelchen für anna-lena den gibt es
aber nur für ein kreuz bei den grünen
sehr gut und jetzt die zweitstimme bei
den linken sonst muss ich das hier
leider zu drehen
entsetzlich da wird alt menschen die
stimme gestohlen senioren die dieses
land eigenhändig aufgebaut haben nachdem
sie es vorher eigenhändig kaputt gemacht
haben
aber was ist denn euer briefwahl problem
am wahlsonntag werden die umschläge
gegen 15 uhr geöffnet die gültigkeit
überprüft dann kommen sie in die ohren
und werden mit allen anderen stimmen
öffentlich ausgezählt
das ist ihre meinung
da wird solange ausgezählt bis berbalk
gewonnen hat das ist fakt anna lena ich
bin als kind vom trampolin gefallen
berbalk und dann wird's aber tabu
booster wie in dem alten gedicht
denke ich an deutschland in der nacht
machte nichts er wählte mal ganz im
ernst wollen wir denn wirklich
amerikanische verhältnisse in den usa
ist doch gerade erst die wahl gestohlen
worden
ich sage nur stopp verstehen wir hatten
sogar überlegt ganz kurz ob wir unsere
anti briefwahl kampagne aus sondern
sollen aber dann ist uns was viel
besseres eingefallen steckt ihn selber
rein fordert die afb denn ein
briefkasten sagt keine badewanne eure
kampagne heißt stecke ihn selber rein
und
selber einstecken nur dann weiß ich dass
er auch wirklich ganz drin ist
der wahlzettel ja aber warum diese
schwierige doppeldeutigkeit
in angst habe ich habe überhaupt absolut
keine ahnung wovon sie reden was ist da
doppeldeutig in erster linie kämpfen wir
gegen wahlbetrug auch mit unserem neuen
spot
beide stimmen afd immer schön rein in
den schlitz
kremiert osten
[Applaus]
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich